et puis cette autre manifestation devant
le ministère de l'économie à bercy avec
un objectif dénoncer les licenciements
et les suppressions de postes alors que
plus de mille plans sociaux étaient
comptabilisés depuis mars 2009 en est le
premier confinement le cortège doit se
rendre devant le ministère du travail
aux invalides on retrouve en direct
notre reportage nadège abderrazak
bonjour nadège alors ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il ya du monde à ce que les
manifestants sont nombreux
[Musique]
à écouter à meyreuil sont un peu plus
d'une centaine de manifestants présents
ici des manifestants qui sont venus d'un
peu partout en france 1 pour dénoncer
vous l'avez dit les licenciements les
suppressions postes et puis à protester
contre l'assurance chômage alors cette
manifestation aujourd'hui elle a débuté
depuis à bercy et le ministère des
finances et de l'économie et le cortège
doit se rendre à destination du
ministère du travail l'objectif est bien
c'est d'interpeller un est les autorités
un public sur leur situation alors on a
beaucoup de talent ici présents à des
salariés en entreprise de textile de un
choix mais également à des facteurs et
quelques et bien quelques professeurs
alors c'est un un cortège qui est très
bien encadrés par les forces de l'ordre
qui sont très nombreuses aujourd'hui
manifestation qui se déroulait dans le
calme malgré quelques fumigènes et puis
une ambiance une ambiance heures
effectivement festive aujourd'hui malgré
la pluie et le mauvais temps présent
dans la capitale aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci on a déjà pour toutes ces
précisions